And after I dump this bucket of ice on my head,...
...I get to nominate three new people to challenge.
So I'm gonna challenge Bill Gates, my partner at Facebook, Sheryl Sandberg,...
...and Netflix's founder and CEO, Reed Hastings.
I'm glad to give to ALS.
It's a great cause, but I wanna accept this challenge.
I wanna do it better than it's been done.
I've been working on this.
I got this design.
There we go, yeah.
It's gonna be great.
I'm here to join the people bringing attention to Lou Gehrig's disease...
...by taking the ALS Ice Bucket Challenge.
I'm gonna challenge three more people.
Elon Musk, Ryan Seacrest and Chris Anderson of TED, consider yourself challenged.
You have 24 hours.
Good luck.